the president's taking aim at former CIA
director John Brennan on Twitter now
this after Brennan has attacked the
president without
rageous accusations totally political
take a look I think he's afraid of the
President of Russia why well I think one
could speculate as to why that the
Russians may have something on him
personally but the fact that he has has
had this fawning attitude toward mr.
Putin has not said anything negative
about him I think continues to you know
say to me that he does have something to
fear I think mr. Putin is very clever in
terms of playing to mr. Trump's interest
in being flattered and also I think mr.
Trump is for whatever reason either
intimidated by mr. Putin afraid of what
he could do or what might come out with
reaction she is the host of CRR TV her
own show of course Michelle Malkin and
by the way it's award-winning and
retired CIA senior intelligence officer
Fox News contributor Daniel Hoffman
because this is about Brennan I know
more people more people that worked in
your line of work that think he is the
absolute worst director we've ever had
and this display of pull up politics and
is whatever involvement people we now
see coming his lying under oath like
clapper people have had it that I know
FBI intelligence and and of course law
enforcement I mean his tweets today read
like partisan politician not a non
partisan retired former director of CIA
and I would just highlight the contrast
between Brennan's tweets and his
unfounded allegations about the
president's speculation that the that
Dada Mir Putin could could blackmail
president Trump contrast that with
President Trump today at CIA
headquarters presiding over the
swearing-in ceremony of Jena hospital he
called CIA officers the most elite
intelligence professionals on he's a
hero to me I thank God she got just like
Mike Pompeo thank God they did what they
did we never would have gotten bin Laden
let me let me turn to you Michelle
Malkin from your perspective you see
this abuse of power you see this deep
state corruption and you're wondering
I'm sure as I am how could this
happen in this country but it did and
it's now unraveling it did and that is
why people like John Brennan are
behaving the way they are behaving
completely unhinged as you say I think
that John Brennan is a bilious
blabbermouth bilious full of bile
contempt and spite not just for our
president but for our country and for
the American people who duly elected I
want to know what he knew and why I
think I want to know what his
involvement is and and I think it's
going to come out and I think that's why
he panicked over the weekend and I think
that there is a small difference between
being a spook a partisan spook for Obama
and being a crook and and that he is
definitely I think cringing in in the
spotlight
I think that Daniel Hoffman was right to
when he observed that the kind of
comments that he has made publicly about
President Trump aren't just something
that harm the White House but harm all
of the good people within the CIA who
are trying to do their jobs as this man
is self-aggrandizing you see the
psychological projection here of John
Brennan using words like self adoring
and self-serving to describe our
president when he's describing himself I
mean if this guy had done his job during
the Obama administration we wouldn't
have had all of the bungles that John
Brennan was entangled in everything from
helping design the lies about the
Benghazi video bungling the Chris Wright
the fast and furious IRA the christmas
underwear bomber and then even going so
far as as to downplaying recidivism of
the Gitmo terrorists and being soft on
jihad the fact is that these guys have
been so invested in their ideological
agenda and and their and their partisan
ship that they were not doing their job
in protecting Americans around the world
no home I mean this with all my heart
I've been the and Michelle has two the
biggest defender of law enforcement my
entire career I want to remind people
this is not rank-and-file intelligence
CIA FBI
this is not in any way shape manner or
form it's the upper echelon and DOJ hey
John Brennan is doing Vladimir Putin's
bidding and for someone who has
criticized the Trump administration for
the way they've handled Russia even
though the Trump administration has
closed down Russian consulates in
Seattle and San Francisco and kicked out
seat 60 Russian officials but John
Brennan is doing what Vladimir Putin
wants by speculating about the president
being subjected to blackmail even though
it's not true and then Brennan walked it
back with the New York Times days after
he said it but the damage is done damage
is done last 15 seconds Michelle you
know the biggest threat we face right
now is the three-headed Hydra of the
police state the deep state and the
Fourth Estate all the incestuous
relationships the leaks and the the self
profiteering by people like John Brennan
and his ilk